would you get married or are you married
I was married yes separated
for the last two years near the tree
went nicely we went
ways
um yeah amazing man amazing awesome
awesome okay did you did you initiate
divorce uh I did yes because I fall in
love with somebody else and I knew
there's nothing that we can work on
anymore and that's my part is something
wait a minute wait a minute
so hang on you said you're so so you've
got you had an amazing man yeah and what
you had you had an affair no
but you found someone else I didn't
found it just it happened you know
nothing just happened well there you go
everything happens for the reason so
that was must be a reason where was he
so like how did you meet the other guy
uh so we moved in Canada
and that was like I think after six
months later
well no I'm saying like you had to meet
him somehow
like at work yeah yeah yeah you met so
you met another guy at work yeah and
then you fell in love with the other guy
yeah but you didn't cheat you're saying
it was like an emotional thing yeah and
then you realized you're in love with
him yeah and did you are you still with
the other guy I know
so how how long were you with the second
guy uh for two years two years
um looking back was it worth it uh of
course
we have to learn from our own lessons
and our own mistakes you know so even
like getting married I love the man you
know when I always gonna love him did
you have children with the with your
husband no I didn't no that sounds toxic
way
do you mean I just explained that like
five minutes ago that same similar
scenario but like that's your life
approach you know that's how you live
your life so everybody like we're all
unique we're all different do you think
that was do you think that was selfish
after you made vows like you made vows
that you're going to be with this guy
for the rest of your life blah blah blah
do you think it was selfish what you've
done uh no
really yeah no do you think it was a
mistake uh no
so if you're you're single now uh yes so
if you stayed single the rest of your
life would it be a mistake then
um probably not because I'm quite happy
with myself so you feel contempt with
how everything's going on so far yeah
absolutely
if I was I'm speaking from like my
perspective I was in your position I'd
be like dang I should have just stayed
with my husband I would be I don't know
because I wanna I want to get married I
want to like have a family have kids and
just be able to like do the things that
I've done with my family do it with my
kids and my husband and so if I was in
that position and like nothing after the
divorce worked out and I was like I left
my husband for this I'm not saying this
to like make you feel bad anyways I'm
just saying it from my perspective if I
was it
um I would just I'd be distraught I'd be
running please I'd be like please
if you don't mind me Austin how did he
deal with the divorce when you came to
him and you said don't want a divorce so
I found somebody else how did he deal
with that he was super supportive super
supportive yeah it's like it's so so
pity because he's like even before we
got married because like I had this
feeling that that we even like meant to
be together in case that even back then
I already thought about divorce you know
and then he's like I never said anything
so I thought we're gonna work through it
and then at the end of the day it still
came to that day that now you actually
want to get divorced so the kids like
it's kind of mutual feeling but at the
same time it's like so sad that you know
we like we're planning so many different
things and we were so good together you
know I used to do still like are you
still friends or well we kind the
friends but we don't talk anymore yeah
at all do you think love is a feeling or
a choice
I think it's a feeling for sure his
energy and there's always the you know
always energies around there so then
don't you do you would you want to get
married again
I do I do and I do believe that like we
all have like our proper person to each
other how long do you want to be married
wait wait wait how long do you want to
be married
how long so if you got married again how
long again like it's not even about the
marriage I just want to have that person
you know to spend like the Integrity
with you know it's not even a lifetime
anymore you know yeah so I've assuming
the experience I just want to explain
how men like hear what you're saying so
when when men hear this and I think as a
woman like we understand what you're
saying a little better but when men hear
this it's like a red flag because that
means you're gonna go if you're just not
feeling it it is multiple red flags as a
man listening to your story yeah I'm
sitting there thinking
you ain't just gonna marry me and just
be like oh well I felt this way and I'm
gonna leave and there's no way I if I
heard that story as a man I'm like that
I ain't getting married to you I think
what's exactly and that's the point for
life that I never go to anybody or
everybody even if I go to somebody
that's always thought about it it's
always has to be like something so in my
life that's in general there's like you
know uh listen I'm not saying you should
be someone that you don't want to be
with but like I want to know how do you
love someone
without first liking them
[Music]
so did you fall out of like with him you
just didn't like him no no no no no no
no no because you left my man for for
the other guy so I'm saying how do you
love my other guy
without liking him first
so of course you like the person
huh right like I don't really get it
though okay so the guy at work did you
like him first before you you love them
I think so
that's what I'm saying so yeah wasn't
there like a point in that time when
this is what pissed me off bro
so what he's asking is that was there a
point where it came like you liked him
what was the point where you started to
like have feelings fall in love with him
because I'm just thinking like I've had
co-workers before but you'd have to
spend a bunch of time outside of work to
fall in love and isn't that kind of like
inappropriate you know I mean like I'm
just thinking if I was in a marriage and
then my co-worker asked me to hang out
outside of work
yeah and we didn't hang out after work
so and then that was like after like a
month maybe kind of period the thing is
you said that you didn't um have an
affair you said it was kind of an
emotional thing
um it's very hard to believe for a man
that a woman would file for divorce
um
and there's been no sexual contact with
this guy you know I mean it's it's very
hard for a man to hear it would be hard
to believe oh it was just an emotional
thing no we don't we I wouldn't believe
it because they're like in my case it
was it doesn't matter even if I gonna be
with this new guy or not I still gonna
be read on my own and like set
everything clear now and let another
person go to to move on with his own
life it's like if we're gonna continue
working and working it's like yes we can
reach that point where we can actually
like learn to love each other again in
the way like with maybe passion way or
some kind of different way but again you
know that that's not the person you want
to be with because and you know that he
knew already that's the point it was
that it was mutual agreement I think
we're sold a dream as women because like
you only get passionate love as many of
you know I was just banned on Tick Tock
and we are demonetized on a daily basis
on this platform if you want to help
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible